[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
doors that free to think of it Dear John
and Hank it's a comedy podcast for two
brothers answer all your questions give
you TBS advice and bring you the week's
news from both Mars and AFC Wimbledon
John what is the elephant in the room Oh
Hank I think we both know what the
elephant in the room is this week it's a
no brainer Elif absolutely two one the
significance of everything we do I mean
they're related David how many times do
I have to make Michael Cohen the
elephant in the room until I get to feel
that magical moment when you also say
Michael Cohen and we can finally have a
Michael Cohen focused podcast segment
which I've been begging you for for
months
Hank all of the most famous podcasters
the way that they get huge is by talking
about Michael Cohen I'm sorry what is
what is the insignificance of everything
that we do just in general like the Sun
is such a very small thing and it's so
very big and the space between the stars
is is immense in the space between the
galaxies Yves even more immense than
that hey we only matter to each other
John and and I guess that's I guess
that's kind of beautiful and okay and
also we matter to each other so
tremendously much right like we all have
the capacity to bring each other solace
and joy and fear and terror and horror
we we matter to each other so much we
matter to other life on Earth so much we
matter a little bit to the moon we might
even eventually matter some to Mars so I
try I think that our mattering is
expanding which is great but I think the
core of our mattering is always going to
be in how we treat each other and how we
take care of each other and speaking of
taking care of people who have taken
care of you Michael Cohen the quasi
attorney of the President of the United
States who is under investigation for
a wide variety of crimes might be
flippin yeah I mean I feel like the
moment if I'm Michael Cohen the moment
president Donald Trump gets elected
president I'm like this isn't gonna turn
out great for me is it I bet that yes I
would think that would be my first
thought I would think I am going to be
in the spotlight and yeah I feel that if
light is shown in this area of my life
there's going to be some
uncomfortability 'he's right like maybe
do you how many people do you think said
to Donald Trump like you know maybe your
life is not one that needs an excessive
amount of scrutiny like this might not
be something that should be like all the
SH delights shown in all the different
little crevices probably probably the
most the most dangerous thing you could
do for the way that you have lived thus
far is to sign up to be the most looked
at person in the world and to be fair I
think one of the arguments that Trump
supporters will make is that Trump had
very little to gain from the presidency
and in fact in many ways a lot to lose
and so that that would would be an
argument that Trump's presidency really
is born of a desire to serve of a belief
that you know he could bring positive
change to the country and even though it
would negatively affect him personally
it would be worth that sacrifice for the
larger good of the country and that is
an argument
it doesn't jive with other things that I
see completely in in the way that he's
run his administration but I am
definitely open to that argument I just
think that this is a big news story I
think it's an important news story I
think because it's salacious and it has
the feel of gossip at times it doesn't
get treated like an important news story
I've been a little slow burned the
podcast about Watergate that tries to
recreate the experience of Watergate as
it unfolded and something similar was
happening during Watergate where there
was a lot of like oh this is
no salacious stuff about dirty tricks
and with all of these over-the-top
personalities and it only unfolded
slowly that people started to think like
oh and also this is a quite a serious
thing yeah right and Minh and I think
that like both from the perspective of
like the how than its being treated in
the news media but also how it gets
treated in our own heads we're like well
this is about like you know a sex
scandal and that's not like are we are
we still having sex scandals is that
something still that important in this
day and age but it's it's not it's it's
not a safe and I think that like we sort
of like half treat it like a sex scandal
and then you can be written off because
of that but it's not it's part of part
of a lot of different a lot of different
wrongdoings well we'll see we don't know
yet there's a lot we don't know and I
don't want to get ahead of the facts but
did we did we do the thing that you
wanted to do we have our michael cohen
oh no he'll be the elephant in the room
next week don't you worry i just
whenever whenever we figure out what the
elephant in the room is I always just go
to Twitter and look at what the top
trending hashtag is and John this week
it's Michael Cohen it actually was I
should have gone with you I was right
all right well John as you know there
are people who listen to this podcast
and they send us questions and I feel
like we wouldn't be doing our duty
unless we did answer some of their
questions eventually so let's do that
this next question comes from Lauren who
asks dear Hank and John in the
internship I have in my college this
summer one of the major things I'm doing
is calling prospective students to gauge
their interest in school and such I'm
supposed to be a resource to these
potential students so I introduced
myself at the beginning of each call and
leave my phone number sometimes though I
have to call someone who has my same
first name it just feels very weird to
leave a moyes voicemail saying hi Lauren
this is Lauren what should I do
should I lie change my name when it's
rainin it's Lauren you just got to make
a joke out of it yeah no you change your
name not permanently just right make of
the call yeah you see so it doesn't care
frankly if your name is Lawrence all
right and this to me gives you a great
opportunity now you can only do this
when you're calling Lauren's you can't
do it every time because it'll be
seductive and super fun and you'll want
to do
every time and he can't but every time
you're calling a Warren they answer they
say hello and you say hi this is Bette
Midler from Florida State University and
they say what and you say this is Bette
Midler I'm a student at Florida State
University I'm calling because I know
you've been admitted to the school and I
was just wondering how you feel about it
I love that you chose Bette Midler well
I just think it's the perfect Chris but
that's that's a name that prospective
college students will really resonate
with you know because they remember wind
beneath my wings I teach is Bette Bette
Midler is good I think I think in
general like E is something a little bit
obscure as excellent you can also be
like hi Lauren
this is manhole I'm calling from Florida
State University I'm just wanted to let
you know that we're really interested in
and giving you as much information as
you want on on the great programs we
have at FSU it's okay this is you're
onto something here Hank which is that
it what happens when because nobody's
listening at the beginning of the call
anyway what happens when you try an
increasingly obscure and an absurdist
series of things right like what happens
if you're like hi Warren
this is a gang of turkeys calling from
Florida State University there's 17 of
us we were just wondering how you feel
about Florida State's an excellent
classical music program we have four for
classical music majors here among our
gang of 17 turkeys who are making this
phone call be happy to connect you with
one of them directly I'm an anthropology
major hi hi Lauren this is one scissor
now it may be thinking to yourself is
that possible yes because a scissors are
a pair of scissors I'm just one of them
my parent my other parents my other
friend is calling calling a different
Lauren right now I'm basically a knife
anyway this is really great I've had a
really really positive experience here
hey Lauren have you ever been driving
alone at night and you're filled with a
sort of vague melancholy but not an
unpleasant one that's me here too
what do you think would you like to go
to college here don't feel pressure I
know there's a lot of great schools
[Laughter]
urgent help I was hammering some holes
into a belt when I was putting the belt
away I dropped the hammer on the marble
floor and now there's a chip and a dent
in the floor what do I do I live with my
parents and if they see this I'm gonna
be in very big trouble
help talita alright to eat it you're not
gonna be able to do anything about the
dent but you're gonna fix the chip and
you're gonna fix it quickly are you
gonna fix it all John you don't you know
you could you can fix the dent and the
chip how do you fix the dent you get up
you get a sculpture that full gut goes
over the dent that's beautiful and that
everybody would be like wow what an
elegantly placed sculpture such a good
idea way better than my strategy is
super gluing the chip back into where it
chipped off from much much better the
next time your parents come home they're
like what the heck is this and you just
say like oh this is a sculpture that I
made right oh yeah David and your
parents gonna be like this is incredible
and you were like yeah I know I did a
really good job so is where the
sculpture lives by the way it's a
site-specific sculpture it's like I
can't move it around in the room because
then it's just ruined right well then
maybe David's like holding a like a cup
of coffee and it's just very fall or
maybe like David's reaching for the
little tug on the ceiling fan recognized
if you put it anywhere else in the room
like what's he reaching for it doesn't
make any sense
yeah yeah you're welcome to Lita we've
solved your problem comes from Lee Anne
who writes Dear John and Hank I recently
decided to play a matchmaker and set up
two of my friends from different social
circles the day went really well and now
both of them can't stop telling me how
wonderful the other person is as happy
as I am for them how do I stay impartial
what if they start coming to me with
their relationship problems I was okay
with giving them advice before with
other people but now it's just a little
weird because I know both of them so
well should I leave them to it
should I keep a bunch of secrets for
both of them from the other person how
do what what do I do
I don't want to be the middleman
LeeAnn you are you are worried so
worried about a problem that doesn't
exist yet yeah you're good Leigh in this
I mean like you don't know that any of
these things are gonna happen to mean do
you know these people well enough that
they're like they always come to you
with relationship advice with every
relationship they have maybe that's
gonna happen but I don't know maybe it
won't because they are aware that you're
good friends with the other person that
you set them up on the date with and
they're probably gonna be like we'll
probably not gonna go to LeAnn because
the other person is a good friend of
LeAnn
I think that there's a sort of there's
the 95 percent chance that this couple
is gonna be broken up within a month oh
dang John maybe not don't you think I
don't know it'd be interesting you've
done the math more than I have what what
what percentage of relationships last
forever zero do you mean what relation
what do you mean what percentage of
relationships last until death no I mean
what percentage of relationships last
until marriage oh it's got to be pretty
low at least based on my own personal
experience I mean it's very high based
on mine well I suspect that we're
outliers
I suspect the truth is somewhere in the
middle like somewhere between like 48
serious relationships and two yeah yeah
I mean there has to be there has to be
like somebody should somebody have to
have done this research and I can't I
cannot find it and my rehearsal dinner
my friend Dean gave a toast you may
remember this Hank in which he talked
about me coming home from meeting Sarah
for the first time and I came back to
the apartment and I said you know I
think I'm gonna marry that girl I really
do
and Dean said it was only the 17th time
John had said that to me John I found
the graph and the risk of breakup is
very high in the beginning so around 80
75 80 % of couples will break up in the
first year of their relationship which
is actually a little bit you know I kind
of expect to be higher than that
yeah but then a number of couples break
up in their second year right not
everybody like dates for a year and then
gets married and then I I think the
Olean the overall chances that this
relationship is going to be like the
defining romantic relationship of these
two people's lives is under 10 percent
so let's wait to panic okay we're gonna
wait to pay that I completely agree and
in general wait to panic is great great
advice not don't panic I mean it just
like if I could yeah just give it a
couple of breaths
I might tattoo that on me somewhere wait
yeah Japan like I could really stand to
have wait to panic on the inside of my
wrist the other thing that I'd like to
have tattooed somewhere like maybe under
my eyelids so that I could see it every
time I close my eyes would be this is
temporary which is also in all the best
ways in all the worst ways constantly
true yeah it's good it's good to
recognize both because of the good and
the bad hey I feel like we're going a
little dark can we liven things up with
maybe like some grease - or Alvin and
the Chipmunks what do you got for me
although this questions from Alexis who
asks dear Hank and John nobody in my
family eats the first and last pieces of
bread the heel as they were called in
our family I don't know if everybody
else calls us that I feel bad just
throwing those out so you have any
suggestions for what I could do thanks a
lot I don't have a car but if I did it
would be Alexis you eat them no yeah you
make a sandwich out of them and be like
no no no and basically because they're
it's made out of the heel it's sort of
like calorie neutral cuz you're doing a
social good if only that were true
no no you do not eat the dial pieces no
no no no and you do I just slightly took
peanut butter on one of them and put
them together nothing else and it's just
like it's a nice little snack you don't
like it what's wrong with this is there
is there something that I'm missing like
if they're a danger you know when we
were little kids and mom would cut the
crusts off of our peanut butter and
jelly sandwich and they were so good
we got a little older and she stopped
cutting off the crusts because we were
you know older now and that was just the
way the world works you got to learn to
live with a certain amount of suffering
with your peanut butter and jelly yeah
what you're proposing Hank is you're
proposing eating a crust sandwich and
like yeah you know I eat the crust
because of the rest of the sandwich
being like good enough for me to
understand that I have to suffer through
this crust part because I am an adult
and that's how life works right I'm
exactly exactly what I'm telling you
hole crust sandwich I'm saying that you
not only should do this I'm saying that
you have to do this this is part of
being a human being as having some
subpar experiences because this is the
way that the world works and the end
like they baked the bread and the bread
had to have an edge and all of the bread
was food pink yes I mean you know how I
feel about this John ultimately is that
I don't actually care at all and I like
just I went real hard on something that
I have I have like maybe like a 1 out of
10 in terms of the strength of my
opinion well I would also argue that the
strength of your overall argument is
pretty low yeah yeah no I think that's
why my my opinion is also because it was
not a good argument but I don't I don't
mind eating a heel sandwich
I do remember in the past I would
actually go like 2 or 3 slices in to get
like the best bread not just not eat the
heel I wouldn't eat like the second or
third slice yeah I still do that I give
the second and third slices to my
children they don't know the difference
you know what I like about orange
sandwiches so when we make or in a
sandwich now we cut it up and a little
bit so it's easier for me to grab and
eat and like and then you get some
pieces that are crusty but then the
middle ones are like they're they're
basically that like what tiny sandwiches
with no crust and it's very very hard
for me not to eat one or two of those
when he's out of a sandwich have you
ever had a nun crustle I've heard about
them ah oh my god people in the office
eat them oh my god Uncrustables they're
just they're just magic just when you
thought processed food couldn't become
any more perfect along comes the
Uncrustables of peanut butter and jelly
sandwich with no
crusts in a circular shape that if
pressed you can eat all in one bite I've
just googled uncross the ball it looks
like a pie out of pie
it's a delicious peanut butter and jelly
pie this next question comes from
Christopher who writes dear Hank but
mainly John it's my kind of question
Christopher I've been invited to a World
Cup soccer pool by a co-worker on a
related note I just learned that there's
a World Cup this year I don't know
anything about soccer but I want to make
work friends and such and I'm also quite
competitive and I think it's important
that I win this pool so what strategy
should I use or better yet can you just
tell me who's going to win soccer pool
loafer Christopher Christopher I am
happy to help Christopher you're in a
pretty simple situation you would not
have been invited into this World Cup
pool if they did not think that you were
dead money that is a person who will
definitely lose so the worst that can
happen is exactly what everyone else
expects is going to happen if you can
bet on Brazil do if you can bet on
Germany or France or Spain do everyone
else is a long shot but some long shots
are longer than others Saudi Arabia for
instance is not going to win the World
Cup nor is Australia my best darkhorse
pick or AG why there you go that's all I
got good well done John I just found a
youtube video I'm sorry it's something
about soccer makes me immediately open a
new tab I apologize and I do believe in
that and I think I may even make my
whole video this week about how much I
believe in in the goodness of the World
Cup but a video a creator who said if
you eat Uncrustables you need to watch
this and the first comment on it is get
bent you killjoy people started eating
Chipotle when sapote first came out and
everybody was like man this healthy
Mexican food is so healthy and so
delicious I could eat tons of it and
then somebody made a website called
Chipotle calculator calm and you went to
it you told the calculator all the stuff
that was in your burrito and then it
told you that your burrito contains 17
days worth of food
and everybody's response to it was like
hey Chipotle calculator inventor shut up
and go away I'm trying to enjoy my
Chipotle I was happy for five minutes if
you if you eat Uncrustables you need to
watch this oh my god I don't she's got a
whole series and her thumbnails are just
like her holding a piece of food and
then giving a thumbs down alright this
next question comes from Charlie who's
six years old and yet asked a question
that I don't know the answer to which is
something that happens to me all the
time in my life is a father Dear John
and Hank how do you know when you get to
the end of the galaxy do you go right
into the next galaxy Charlie ah that's a
good question because it because it is a
fuzzy boundary between between the
galaxy and not the galaxy anymore
there are sort of like the number of
stars decreases and like there will be
you know basically you have like there's
a hundred around and then there's ten
around and then there's one kind of
nearby and then there's one really far
away but there's a definite distinction
between galaxies and and the way that I
can best illustrate this is that if you
go like half the distance between two
galaxies there won't be any stars in the
sky so if you were just on a planet in
between all two galaxies this this the
sky would just be dark you wouldn't even
know that there are stars you would see
probably some smudges that would be
other galaxies or that would be galaxies
so that wouldn't be other galaxies
because you're not in a galaxy God the
universe is so big yeah that's a really
sort of messed up weird we so yeah so
the short answer is like there is no
sign that says like you're now exiting
the Milky Way galaxy but there's a
tremendous amount of space between most
galaxies yeah and by tremendous I mean
like impossible to wrap my head around
yeah it's real weird I told that to
Catherine we were going through these
questions before before now and I said
to Catherine that you could be in space
and not have any stars in the sky and
she was like
yeah that's what I thought of those
things that I almost wish I didn't know
like I don't really want to know how big
the universe is because it makes my
tummy hurt Hank I want to ask you
another space related question we get a
version of this question
many times every day and I just think
it's time to address it it comes from
Bradley who writes Dear John and Hank
I'm a pretty new nerdfighter and I would
like to thank you both for creating
something positive and also addicting
you're welcome
Bradley although that is what I said
about cigarettes when I was in high
school and it turned out I was wrong so
I hope that we hold up better than
Marlboro Lights did my question is about
the moon I have a friend who saw a
documentary and is now convinced that
the lunar landing never happened ie dad
is not a documentary his reasoning has
to do with the live-streaming of the
event to the entire country if we still
experience significant problems live
streaming events now how could they have
done so in 1969 I personally think that
of course the lunar landing is legit but
this question is interesting to me what
the heck was it like to livestream the
lunar landing how'd they do that so we
the question we get is different
versions of my / my friends / my brother
/ my cousin believed that the earth is
flat or believed that the lunar landing
was faked or but those are the two big
ones these sort of conspiracy theories
that have taken over a certain subset of
online experience mostly this subset of
online experience where in response to
being told you have to do your own
research you have to become your own
expert people try to become their own
experts and along the way conclude that
the earth is flat or that the moon
landing never happened
right and and it's I mean I think that
like Flat Earth is is such an
interesting example of this because like
as soon as like stuff gets called into
question you're like well I'll look into
that and then you can cut like I think
Flat Earth is a good example of it
because you can you can see like
obviously this isn't one that is easy to
get sucked into but you can see all of
the ways in which people justify it and
that allows you to see it through your
own
like what are the things that I might be
really susceptible to and so like how
did they technically livestream it
wasn't of course it precisely live how
did they do that
it's complicated and NASA worked really
hard to make that be a thing and you can
read articles about it there's the you
know one called how NASA broadcast Neil
Armstrong live from the moon on from
popular science and it's very
interesting and it's complicated too
complicated to talk about on this
podcast in large part because a lot of
the technology that they use then
doesn't things like we don't use it
anymore because we've figured out other
ways to do it and I think some of what's
beneath the larger phenomenon here is
that people feel like they can't trust
experts and they feel like they can
trust people who explain stuff to them
in ways that make sense to them and the
truth is at times when trying to explain
stuff science communicators at least
some of them can come across as
condescending which can make somebody
shut down and not want to listen whereas
when people and I've watched some of
these videos about how the earth is flat
they treat their audience in a
particular way that makes makes you feel
like you're being taken seriously and
also reflect something that you probably
believed to be true on some level which
is that people in power people with
elite status use that power and that
elite status to deceive people with less
power in order to prevent them from
getting power that does not mean that
the earth is flat the earth is not flat
and we know that for a lot of reasons it
doesn't mean that the moon landing
didn't happen and we know that for lots
of reasons what I do when I'm thinking
about whether I believe in a conspiracy
theory is I ask myself two questions the
first question I ask is would this
conspiracy theory being true reaffirm my
worldview because if so that may be a
big part of why I believe it's true and
to how many people would have to be
lying to me at the same time for this
conspiracy theory to be true and in the
case of both the moon landing and the
earth being flat we're not talking about
dozens of people we're talking about
tens of
thousands if not hundreds of thousands
of people it's really interesting to me
Hank because something really similar
happened in the early 1970s right around
Watergate with the huge rise of
conspiracy theories and conspiracy
theories being taken much more seriously
books of conspiracy theories being
published by mainstream publishers which
had never happened before
etc and we are again in one of these
moments where we feel like we cannot
trust many of the people who are in
power or many of the power structures
that that we trust to govern our lives
and I think it's a response to that but
I also think you've got to know that
it's a response to that yeah I think
that's absolutely true
and it's it's it's a as a science
communicator it's frustrating and parted
parsh part of it is like I don't want to
engage with it because I think giving it
any air at all only only sort of like
makes people be like well I'm gonna
check for myself and then as you say
like a lot of times what what you hear
is is like what the experts are saying
doesn't make a lot of sense to me and
then there's this alternate viewpoint
that does make sense and the reason that
it makes sense is not because that
viewpoint isn't biased or isn't
incorrect it's because it shares your
same biases it comes at the world from
the place where you already are whereas
the world actually is complicated and
messy and weird and when it comes down
to how particles work and physics works
like that stuff's never gonna make
intuitive sense because it doesn't make
sense and when it comes to how like how
NASA broadcast the moon landing live it
doesn't like it's really hard to
understand and like you can find lots of
places in that in that article you're
gonna be like well I don't actually I
don't get this because you don't get it
and I don't get it and I don't care
enough like even as a person who's like
intensely curious about that stuff I'm
not curious enough to try and figure out
how like a UHF H works like I just don't
know but it's but it comes down to this
idea that I can't trust experts so I'm
going to become my own expert and the
problem with that is that you are not
going to be and I don't mean just you I
mean any right no one is going to be a
really good expert in both particle
physics and
you know beer making no one is gonna be
a really good expert in both carpentry
and astrophysics like or maybe you could
do both those but you can't do
everything and so we have to trust on
some level people who devote their
professional lives to a subject we have
to at least take them seriously
which reminds me Jonna this podcast is
brought to you by everyone lying to you
at the same time everyone in the world
lying at the same time it's how all the
most dastardly deeds get done that is
kind of how I felt in middle school all
the time so now I have a newfound
sympathy for that worldview today's
podcast is also brought to you by a
vague sense of melancholy a vague sense
of melancholy calling you on the phone
to learn your interest level in Florida
State University this podcast has also
brought to you by a statue of David with
a very full cup of very hot coffee
do not move it mom and dad there is no
particular reason why it has to be right
there but I say that it does
and lastly today's podcast is brought to
you by a starless sky a starless sky if
you've ever been far enough out in the
water not to be able to see land imagine
being far enough out into the universe
not to be able to see anything and
finally the podcast is brought to you by
our actual sponsor hellofresh hellofresh
is a meal kit delivery service that
shops and plans and delivers
step-by-step recipes and pre measured
ingredients so you can cook and eat and
enjoy and I feel like Hello fresh they
take into consideration like how hard
it's gonna be to prep and also how hard
it's gonna be to clean up which I really
appreciate because I'm the one that does
the dishes in the house yeah I also feel
that hellofresh does a nice job at what
I call dish use minimization I have to
say I ate a hell of fresh dinner last
night Sarah and I made flat breads and
it was so good I also had a hello fresh
dinner last night I had we had like
asparagus ravioli with like crusty
crusts and cheese cheese on it it was
really good hella fresh it's all of the
fun of cooking for me without all of
this
wrath of cooking all the things that I
find really intimidating hellofresh
covers for me and you can have meal
options from all around the world all
kinds of different no matter no matter
who you are you can find a meal that you
will find delicious and that you will be
able to cook and if nothing else it has
made me feel so much more confident in
the kitchen which is so important like a
lot of cooking is confidence it's you
know having that base level of knowledge
where you can get stuff done and I just
love it it is a chance for Sara and I to
be in the kitchen making food an hour
and evening talking going over our day
without all of the usual stress of meal
planning so you should check out
hellofresh
and I think that you get a discount
right Hank you do you get $30 off your
first week of hellofresh we go to hello
fresh comm slash dear Hank
you could also hello fresh comm slash
Dear John and you got to enter the promo
code dear Hank or Dear John they'll both
work but hellofresh comm slash Dear John
is your ideal hellofresh location and
I've been using hella fresh for you know
before we before they were sponsored on
the podcast and and for probably more
than a year now and I have like we've
never made something bad it's always
turned out really good and I'm and I'm
happy to have this sort of like time in
our lives like after with the baby to
bed we make dinner together and that's
also a good a good time to hang out and
and have a home-cooked meal so how I
remember when my kids would go to bed
before dinner he had good it's good now
nice yeah that's nice that that won't
last forever if you go there's nice
things about them getting older to like
no my kids not only like will they talk
to me but like they've started to watch
movies that I like mmm yeah I mean at
the moment Oren doesn't watch any movies
except for you know maybe a glimpse of
the one that we're watching but but the
content that he seems to prefer on
YouTube is definitely not the content
that I would choose to watch yeah I mean
it's slow pace and just lots of really
big eyes like honestly I think if they
if the whole iPad just turned into a pay
of gigantic eyes he would be like yes
this is a good show anyway for $30 off
your first week at hellofresh go to hell
fresh calm slash dear Hank and into the
code dear Hank on checkout they get that
to get that discount this next question
comes from Courtney who writes Dear John
and Hank my brothers three years my
senior but he never learned how to drive
I however have been driving for almost a
year now who should be able to sit
shotgun when we're both in the car with
our mom oh that's hot did I understand
the relationship between the first words
of question in the second part of the
question but it goes on I firmly
maintain that I have usurped the
primogeniture birthright to the front
what Wow by successfully owning and
operating a vehicle first he does not
share this feeling whoo-hah your brother
convinced you that there is a
primogeniture birthright to the front
seat i that is that is the most
remarkable thing and then and the next
step to think that you could that like
you can usurp that through the
acquisition of a of just one particular
skill that you have arbitrarily selected
obviously the person who gets shotgun is
the perfect person who says shotgun
first and that needs to have been
established early on and you have maybe
already lost that battle no no no no no
no this is no it's not too late Hank
you've given up on Courtney and that's a
mistake so here's the deal I think this
person is not from the United States I'm
judging this on the fact that they know
how to spell primogeniture which is not
an idea we have here in America
really unfortunately otherwise I would
get all that sweet sweet mom and dad
money and Hank would be left out in the
cold I don't even know I don't know what
it means either it means like the first
son gets all the money okay well the
good news is John that you're good yeah
I mean I could be better I mean I want
to cut that but I bet Nick's gonna keep
it in all right
point being I assume that this person is
from problem maybe England and therefore
they believe
certain rights are passed down from
generation to generation to the oldest
child or whatever I don't understand why
shotgun would be one of those rights but
I certainly don't understand why
learning out a drive earlier would mean
that you no longer shotgun Courtney
there is an existing foolproof strategy
I got so passionate I just dropped the
phone and Hank can't hear me good I
can't I can't hear what's happening hey
I dropped the phone hold on I'm coming
back I was I was literally pounding my
armchair which resulted in me dropping
the phone there is an existing foolproof
strategy for this Courtney which is that
when you are walking to the car from the
moment you leave whatever building you
are in to the moment that you are
outside in the same outside that you
will be in until you reach the car from
that moment it is possible at any point
in that moment to call Shotgun and if
you call Shotgun you get to sit in the
passenger seat it is that simple
those are the rules of shotgun forget
all of this birthright shotgun crap you
get shotgun by calling shotgun that's
right that's right this is not a
bat-like we have moved beyond the idea
of absolute monarchy this is about this
is about who is clever enough fast
enough and willful enough to call
shotgun first but I want to be clear you
can't call Shotgun like the moment you
get out of the car you can't call
Shotgun until you were in the same
outdoor space that you will continually
be in until you enter the Royal car yes
that's the rule so if you're first out
the door and you yell shotgun and
they're still inside that counts hmm
to me that's an open question that's
that is what that is part of it part of
being at having a get-up-and-go attitude
being the first out the door and your
mom's gonna appreciate that too
everybody's out to the car and you're
standing there by the door and he like
your brothers walking up and you say
shotgun before he steps steps on that
first paving stone you are the winner
all right all right I buy it Hank before
we get to the all-important news from
Mars and AFC Wimbledon I need to read
this project for awesome message from a
man
to Ryan and Marshall Amanda donated to
the project for awesome to get us to
read this message and we will read it
now for my two favorite guys Thank You
Amanda
not John and Hank oh well I'll keep
reading anyway who just happened to be
two awesome husbands and dads I couldn't
think of a better way to say how awesome
you both are than from two of the
coolest people I know thanks for being
in my life and for being a great husband
and son Ryan and Marshall so Ryan
Marshall thank you for being a great
husband and son Amanda thank you for
donating to the project for awesome and
for warming hearts everywhere
yes all right John we got some
Corrections and and responses we got
savanah who is a vocalist on one of the
world's largest cruise ships and just
wanted to let us know that there are
people who listen to the pod from a boat
though often times they have to download
the pod beforehand because Wi-Fi on the
boat is not super great also Daniel who
is an engineer at the NASA Jet
Propulsion Laboratory working on the
Mars helicopter yes do you have Hanks
dream job well you certainly have my
attention this is very exciting I was
ecstatic to hear Hank discuss our
project in that a recent podcast episode
I do have a very small correction and I
got very nervous when I read that but
it's okay regarding a statement that
Hank made there will be no way to test
precisely how good at its job it will be
until it is there because it won't be
able to fly on a place that is exactly
like Mars until it gets there and I
wanted to mention this is Daniel again I
wanted to mention that wow this is
technically true so I guess it's not
quite a correction we are in the middle
of an extensive test campaign to
simulate Mars light conditions as best
we can for example in this video that
nASA released which we'll put on the
patreon there's footage of our free
flight testing this test was conducted
inside our 25 foot diameter vacuum
chamber at Mars pressure while an
offload system simulated Mars as gravity
the health I don't know how that works
but it's very cool the helicopter
successfully ascended traveled to a
waypoint and then landed multiple times
over the course of the test hopefully we
will see similar success in all of our
tests in case in which case we can be
recently confident confident that the
helicopter will
work on Mars when it gets there
thankfully there are no liens on Mars
Daniel I mean that we know of yet we
won't know for sure till we have a
helicopter fly over the whole drannit
and chariot that the mayor's can't have
that's what we can't have humans on Mars
yet there could be a lion
just tank in case you thought we were
gonna get through that question without
Daniel thinking that neither of us is an
idiot I mean John you never know there
could be whole underground systems of
caves that are at high pressure and
contain mostly lions I mean is there any
possibility that Mars is flat that's all
fat something that I've wondered about
flat earth-like do they think that all
the planets are flat like are they just
like disks out there in space or likely
we see them rotating so we know that
other planets aren't flat it's just that
earth is flat and none of the other
planets are I don't really I don't think
I don't think we're gonna convince a
single flat earth or on this podcast as
you know I have become increasingly
convinced that no one who currently
believes anything on the internet can
have their mind changed by anyone else
or anything else on the Internet yeah is
the time for the news from Mars and AFC
Wimbledon then oh it is time for the
news from Mars and AFC Wimbledon do you
want me to go first with the Mars news
because it's very big and it's very good
and it's very very big and it's multiple
yes yes yes so occasionally NASA will
have these press conferences where they
say we've got some big Mars news and
when NASA says we got some big Mars news
and we're going to do a press conference
a few science communicator you look at
who's gonna be at the press conference
and you can have a pretty good idea of
what kind of news it's gonna be and
usually you're like well I look to the
press conference I hope to who's on it
and it's not gonna be about the fact
that there's life on Mars but this time
kind of like maybe this would have been
the panel of people like partially that
they would have talking about the fact
that they found like life on Mars and so
of course like all the science
communication world is like it's not
life on Mars like I'm not like I feel
like I would have gotten somebody like
somebody would have leaked something to
me I would have heard about this they
would have been like a lot more hobb up
there would be a lot more buzz but of
course everyone is like
but maybe and so what in fact two
different things one after curiosities
you know hanging out on Mars for a long
time now it's been able to get regular
measurements of methane concentrations
in the Martian atmosphere to the extent
that it can now see a seasonal variation
so in the summertime there's more
methane in the Martian atmosphere and in
the wintertime there's less here on
earth the atmosphere remains almost
entirely consistent except for water
vapor throughout seasons weird why so
they think that a one this definitely
means that method like it seems like
methane is being released continuously
and thus it is being replenished by some
system so more methane is being created
in the side of Mars and then as the
surface of Mars heats up there's these
like methane containing compounds that
are like icy methane water compound
things called clathrates and the clouds
rains will you know some sublimate so go
directly from a solid to a gaseous form
and the methane will get released and
then and then leave the atmosphere the
way that the Martian atmosphere leaves
the planet or Rees elyda Phi under the
surface in the wintertime but it
continued there continues to be the same
amount every year so it's like it's
coming from somewhere and they think
probably some geologic process which
would indicate a pretty active geology
inside of Mars which is not something
that we've super anticipated and the the
other potential source of the methane
could be microorganisms that is not
something that they're talking about
actively or seriously but that is how am
i think it's produced on earth is almost
entirely by microorganisms that was also
produced by some geologic processes I
think and then there's the other piece
of the news which is like very like also
life related that they in mudstone which
is a sedimentary rock that gets left
behind after you know like from silt on
the bottom of a lake so they crushed up
some mud stone basically heated it up a
bunch and found a lot of different
organic compounds meaning meaning
compounds that contain carbon and all of
life on Earth is carbon-based it is why
we call
carbon atoms organic compounds and and
what they can't tell is precisely what
compound these compounds were originally
because curiosity cannot dig very deep
into a rock it can only go like a few
millimeters or centimeters and all of
those compounds over the last three
billion years since they were first
trapped in that mud stone would have
been would have deteriorated because of
like being hit by solar radiation so
there's no way to tell what those
compounds were originally but they are
definitely like you know chains of
carbon compounds which can again be
created by biological or non-biological
systems like comets have amino acids on
them not because there's life there but
because you know lots of different
processes with water and sunlight can
create amino acids so what does it mean
it means that we like curiosity is
making strides toward better
understanding the chemistry and geology
of Mars and also that like it is very
earth-like and back three
three-and-a-half billion years ago it
would have been a like a place that
looks pretty habitable pretty you know
friendly to life as we know it so this
is something I've been wondering a lot
about lately Hank is there really a
bright bright line between alive and not
alive when it comes to organic compounds
because it seems to me that there are
some fuzziness --is at least in life on
earth yeah there are definitely
fuzziness 'iz in terms of what what life
is chemical life you know like viruses
people will say aren't alive but they
are capable of replicating themselves
they are capable of moving around right
not really moving around but like sort
of getting to the place where they want
to be and and so like yes there's
there's a little bit of complexity there
really the idea is that the sort of
thought in the sort of space between
chemistry and biology world is is that
if you have a self-replicating chemical
system
it will move itself toward complexity in
a way that like like in sort of an
inevitable fashion that will make it
clear that whatever that is it is life
and so and so the idea is that unlike as
planetary like science level on a
planetary biology level that you're
gonna like if there's anything like life
there will be something that is
obviously life now whether whether we're
able to sort of like understand it as
life because all the tests that we
currently use to determine whether
there's like a living system happening
are really based on the chemistry of our
life that's up in the air and also like
a huge question because if if the system
that that life uses is identical to act
the life on our planet then one that
raises the question of whether that's
that's just you know like it
contamination from from Earth or weather
like all like life on Mars and Earth
arose from the same source whether that
was Mars life getting to earth and and
all all of us being Martians or earth
life getting to Mars and and existing
there for a little while after like
hitchhiking on an asteroid asteroid or a
meteorite that was ejected from the
surface of one of those planets or some
external third source that just likes
like seeds the entire universe with life
is is the big question well I mean that
is a big interesting weird question
speaking of big interesting weird
questions when is AFC Wimbledon going to
move into their new stadium so the hope
had been Hank that the new plough lane
would be finished in time for the
beginning of the 2019 2020 season that's
not next season but the season after and
that also would mean that even if we
were to get relegated next season which
were definitely favourites for at the
moment we would begin life at the new
plow lane at the very worst in league
two so still in the Football League
still a full-time professional team and
all that stuff huh Hank I don't know if
you've ever engaged in a house
renovation project but if you have
you're likely familiar
with contractor timelines and then the
actuals or progress of days and nights
as they are observed with the Sun rising
and setting and how different those the
sense of days are between what your
contractor thinks that day looks like
and what the Sun thinks a day looks like
that appears to not only be a problem
for residential home renovations in
Indianapolis but also a problem for AFC
Wimbledon
it looks like the demolition of the
greyhound stadium where plow lane will
be built is going slower than expected
and now it looks like at the earliest
AFC wimbledon will not be moving into
the new plow lane until midway through
that 2019 2020 season at least according
to an article in The Evening Standard so
we'll see but you know the race for life
on Mars versus the race to get to the
new plane it's back on well as long as
as long as we get humans there by 2028
in both places I'm good ok all right
Hank what was your phrase of the week I
completely forgot about phrases of the
week I mean you even wrote phrase of the
week in the in the document did I know
somebody that I didn't base my phrase
the week what was my phrasing I do not
know John I am bad at the game I
apologize to everyone well I don't even
think we would still be playing the game
if it weren't for all of these lovely
project for awesome donors who donated
phrases of the week this week's was
donated by Otto and my phrase of the
week was a gang of Turkey ah dang it I
that was exact that was the thing I was
trying to think of I was like what was
between the scissor and the of the other
thing ha got a gang of turkeys this
beautiful John Thank You Otto and for
that wonderful gang of turkeys because
it allowed us to have a really enjoyable
moment together so thanks Otto hey yeah
we learned today well I also got to say
that Kelly Naylor suggested my phrase to
the week which was jell-o salad which I
feel like I would have perfectly easily
gotten into the pond
guess I'm totally totally hey Laura this
is a jello salad calling from Florida
State University kind of hold on I'm
sorry if you heard that I just got a bit
of a jiggle but ya know I'm back hi how
are you today
alright John what did we learn today
well we learned that there are places in
space where the sky ain't got no stars
we learned that you got invited into
that World Cup pool because everyone
expects you to lose we learned that no
matter what the situation is if at all
possible wait to panic and finally we
learned that John feeds his children the
less desirable pieces of bread oh man
good thing they don't listen to the pod
okay thank you for potting with me
thanks to everybody for auditioning
again you can go over to our patreon at
patreon.com slash dear Hank and John and
see all kinds of special updates you
don't have to pay to get them although
if you want to pay you're more than
welcome to we're about to go record our
patreon only podcast this week in Ryan's
which is just the 10 worst podcasting
minutes of your week but we appreciate
everybody who donates there and listens
to it and also everybody who sends in
questions thank you for all your
wonderful questions if you have
questions floors please email us a tank
and John at gmail.com this podcast is
edited by Nicholas Jenkins it's produced
by rosianna halse rojas and Sheridan
Gibson our head of community and
communications is Victoria bon giorno
and the music that you hearing now at
the beginning of the podcast is by the
great gunnarolla and as they say in our
hometown don't forget to be awesome
[Music]